no shadow is the only person to beat all
Sun in sets today and now all signs all
the way here in the grand mouth taking a
look at that beautiful pure arts limited
trophy thinking about his potential to
lock away with that after just a couple
more sets here tonight but there you
have them setting up for the match
Chickering from Japan holds on from
Korea grand finals three out of five
coming your way and we've got chicken on
the winter side of the bracket
nobody said man he said look man this is
a Jeff this is Japan boy game I want to
bring it back Chickering the last person
represent Japan who has a chance old son
the young gun this coming all the way
I'm telling you man he's one of those
guys people like yeah he's really good
but he slipped under the radar and now
here he is sitting on the stage for
grand finals this year one story the
match we just saw I should have touched
on this before but it was really
old-school versus new-school Korea right
oh yeah old-school legend Korea Ulsan
part of that new school no that's and
that's a very big thing to point out I
mean we've seen these guys in
exhibitions we've seen them playing all
year also I'm one of those guys did did
start to get picking up to where he's
gonna see him in this Tekken World Tour
until later in the year I was getting
more on sharp like is he gonna be here
is he gonna be here and here he is
holding it holding down the fort even
crazy if you think about it knee
couldn't take out chicken right
old-school Korea couldn't take out
chicken but now the new school is coming
to have their chance of getting it done
that is that is crazy
that is so crazy oh boy here we go it's
time for the grand final make some noise
and gentlemen Tekken World Tour 2019
final Chickering vs. old son
all right last day on earth last day of
the 2019 Tekken world tour that's what
this is game on
Akuma coming out again not even sound
wasn't even paying attention
surprise the prize GWT final with the
Koopa off course
we thought we were safe we thought we
were done with the baby faded partners
of his friend his face like a chicken
when a pack is dead what countries even
represented right exactly
he's put this in his back pocket but I
told you I was telling he was like yeah
baby streams and he definitely runs the
cool but no like I he's never gonna pull
it out doing this homework that's what
he's editing to be raising God want he's
packed and guy I want some revenge now
three Wow mister tracking move after the
deep in plenty I mean he's still playing
ridiculous looking tries to sidestep and
chick her and making the adjustment to
try to catch him it's not gonna work
Ultron takes around number one top on it
first round it looks so clean they're
like you think I didn't do my holes for
a cool becoming it took this turn this
turn everybody thinks they're and
everybody's practicing against me : and
cigarettes like yeah I've been
practicing with the corner for the power
crush the low is gonna take care of that
though that new power crush on top of it
look people would like four four five on
this is some secret cool Jesus
consistently don't you too every time at
that point range is like yo chill out
for three shell out for three I mean I
like the special Castle attacks the
right it's just a poll real hurricane
kicked it in the combo down for all four
for four
it was chicken he is the monkey oh he is
trying to close this bad boy out doesn't
get a loss flat get off of me frosted
flakes spins the race drive try to fade
out a deeper stuff with chickadees so
save Oh magic Park
wait no rage though he's readjusting for
the wall here doesn't quite reach it
though
okay block
or three Oh fireball yeah you never seen
that before happy cuz okay yeah so the
hell is that statue chick chick rent
looking good in this first game no also
I started off with a blast over bowl-cut
sidewalk now watch no one stops a short
talk ol time man his hit ratio on that
is ridiculous right a few things just
like yes oh good option like only if
they trying to hit a pond every second
it'll come out paint you gotta fix calm
in the check they're keeping it simple
the back to variety with all signs saw
it coming
final round first gaining fun yeah
chickens gonna have a bar to work with
you there it is land the focused attack
here comes the combo and the wall crowd
behind them yo Japan getting loud up
here hey big damage any steel has a ball
Tom moving it down for one it's what I'm
talking about all side even though he's
out goes right back to that movie sticks
to the plan got splattered on the wall
that damage as long as we're happy right
now shooting out there doing Dragon
Punch I ain't gonna calm down
first gave to chicken with you kuba oh
[Music]
man
all sigh get some support out there gods
if you like old sign to take this and
reset it make some noise
yeah a lot of supporters out there what
about Chikara in Japan crowd you guys
want Chickering to take it make some
noise man is pretty split man but it
definitely split is getting more a look
at me it's more support coming for all
sign to it is these matches go on an old
son going to the infinite state who seen
him do his time and time again pretty
decent strategy against Akuma you've
done wall wasn't there last time we're
gonna kill them man I don't think that
was gonna happen I don't think so is a
weird way to die but it worked out right
the Waldos is a little bit of damage
last punch combo we've seen also I get
some amazing runs off of his low pair he
did that off of a forward that that was
beautiful Noor 3 once again old side is
trying to stop too I'm feeling so
confident that 1 1 into hurricane kick
no Peter on the side focus canceled on
the - keep that pressure guard ship
damaged down 4-1 again I love tolls
using another wave that's coming yep
that was something bigger good bit oh
wow seconds left on the clock side steps
the fireball ok play is it raised again
we try to use it
I've seen super Akuma use it and now you
see checker and using it makes it a lot
of sense yeah old son you know you just
barely ran it that's the last second you
try to get a whip punch I'm pretty sure
but it just in reach further than you
expected it's a movie don't see a lot
and game number 2 still looking good for
Chickering old signs just trying so hard
to figure out this puzzle this chicken
chicken Akuma block the down for full
launch here Bowl sake
Tiger gonna push him away mm-hmm Wow
barely out of range that fat cash this
has been saving man the site since on
top of it just great sidestep going for
the defensive moves in a lot of these
situations and is working out but now
also getting real close to get this
second round number two
poke oh you run for the run at you and
go long for it at this tiny pixel what
the range are you would do so much
damage wait doesn't he's a ranger that
turn into the demon and that was very
that was very but something I've seen a
lot of other season Akuma players do
that is two rounds at game number two
and he is looking so calm up there right
now not a worry in the world of how to
go up to 2-0 here in the grand finals
for for just backs up it takes the flash
punch combo I like that option is that
quite a few answers for a few of those
beam and flips they all been working out
a seems like with an octa for this bring
kick you from chick with he's keeping
Assad guessing from everywhere even from
the ground hold on does not know when to
go in and we've seen also I'll pick
apart a lot of the other contestant
today he looks palpable today like you
say it man talked about that a little
earlier oh my god right now this is this
situation chickens made multiple times
in this set so far bull's eye goes away
quickly eight seconds the big block that
one suffer bolts on there he needed that
what he really needed that definitely
needed out chickens plants so called
running to
[Music]
now for expens to beat her to keep the
pressure both side takes its turn back
down for one oh really just gonna wait
for it I do not blame her though
chicken is Oklahoma it's just looking
sharp looks like he's been playing a
cool ball day right it looks like easy
you didn't just pick it right now nope
did you guys do this look I've been
practicing this character for a long
time
don't even worry about don't you worry
bro you guys been complaining about it
out there playing with oh my god doesn't
get the combo you dumped the grab him 12
seconds on the clock old son has rage
can't he find something though he's
behind the life with just 5 seconds here
left on clock now snatch a kick rage for
kuma chicken his final round gave to man
beans are close close around old son is
getting the hang of baby now spring kick
they're gonna get a trade anyway even if
he had to hang around so close one
mistake that's all taken it now and
Jenny he's behind by 35% oh no this is
not good he's not dead he's in trouble
he's in big trouble
abort one gets jabbed out all side
trying to start some offense blocks the
wild family for at the more than three
again we're going to the final match
potentially if Chickering can keep it
together
if Chickering can wants again we're
gonna have a brand new grand champion
here for the techni world tour he is
very close to making it happen here old
sod knocking a monkey around this Bob
he's gonna stick to Kazumi the whole way
through here but he's down to game he's
gotta win three games straight here with
this cuz we just to get a reset he's
starting to figure things out a little
bit I feel like but he's so far behind
you can already tell he's starting to
piece things together he's like I need
to be here I need to stop him from doing
these
he's getting very pre-emptive with the
jabs not as Meany down for once and not
even as meaning running tools and I feel
like that's because of what chicken is
doing putting those fireballs out there
and using that focus cancer to kind of
make you second guess and hesitate and
chicken just looked out into the crowd a
second okay Val it'll nod there he's
just trying to stay composed trying to
close us out here how's he huge Lee
doesn't want to blow it while standing
one first a little bit of damage goes to
chicory that one three once again he's
doing such a good job of keeping all
sign of bay within that lone pair is
gonna be important something that he may
need to do more in the set however at
the same time that for Smith we took so
much mint damage to him and it just
keeps him at bay makes me second-guess
that entry like you know what maybe I
should be careful before I go in and
start trying to use these now for once
again look at that every time jab you
get to the rest of the range for three
entry time and he's got such a brown
base to come right you don't see jumps
very few demon flips just stays on the
ground whole timing now hold on with the
light loop with ten seconds ago and
right now chickens gonna have the bar
meter doesn't even get a use at this
route old son on the board first
look he went down seven seconds still
left on the clock yeah Olson has to play
the style the entire way through cannot
get impatient and can I get ahead of
himself
focus just me get out
you got a bar though you better be
careful mm-hmm this is when all sign
needs to get everything started going
down for kick gotta play a lot more
compact you don't want to do too many
more risky moves and I feel like all
sign knows this has a lead right now
versus chickie
pull the trigger create me it I feel
like old son of adapted now he's playing
the same style chicken is using against
him
and it's working out in his favor oh
three now three yep got the calm with a
focused attack spend one bar and now
he's got a wife who's just ten seconds
ago rage muffles I didn't pull trigger
Oh neither and once again we're down to
the very last seconds of God old son he
let Attila fire ball hat decide that
boom give him the tiger okay all sigh
coming alive
there you go rip right walk off the
stage don't come back
get off of me full mark and you spit it
man is the whateleys you know wait to
use this meter so smartly a whole
sidestepping her all right - lo Perry
again from old side alright still not in
the lead he isn't raised though damage
is gonna look really good interesting
choice not used unblock the shoulder
shoulder and even new didn't even use
any of the veto just saved now recognize
the situation use the character dub
okay and this is what separates Akuma
players right this is what separates
like guys like a teef buddy and honey
from all the other cool places we see
out there hitting these commas
consistently not ease yeah I feel like
wow the jab I think he's trying to run
slide yeah that wasn't the shoulder
I have to pull off no magic eat it just
floats about for three once again
man look at the chick right now just
standing still he's trying to get him to
do so and all stuff not taking the base
like I know you wanted to do something
I'm not gonna hit another but right now
chicken does have that meter he can get
anything with one column oh my gosh
and just like that and his tournament
point for Chickering old son needs to do
something big right now he needs this
round needs this round give himself a
breather give himself another match to
work with things and possibly the lay it
towards a recent power crush it's worked
out from before oh they'll confirm the
f-80c look at the damage of their huge
lead for Chickering to close out the
tournament to close out the door oh hold
on don't let him do it don't let them do
it back that's the wild check your
jacket World Tour Finals champion look
at Japan running up to the stage
Missy you you up there you see everybody
up on the stage shooty ran up claiming
the prize you see nobody up there he
told you it was a Japan game and now you
see Chickering taking the twt 2019 what
are showing look at this camaraderie
from Japan here I don't remember the
last time I saw it they all come
together it doesn't matter what just
boxers it doesn't matter what region
you're from you're all celebrating
together for Chickering they're gonna
try to lift the bumper a state champion
2019 is Ching current yo ladies and
gentlemen make some noise but check
around
yo but guys please let us not forget
make some noise for faith Oh son what
assure you gonna be going home with
second place great your boat all my
goods it came down the wire and of
course chicken getting it done with a
kuma that really wraps up 20:19 first
right that is definitely a wrap 20:19 I
mean we had our kuma actually take the
twt finals and they also waited to the
very last second to pull it out we
haven't seen him play Okuma at all and
he waited till the grand finals to do so
and look what it got three zero gets the
sweep in the grand finals impressive
stuff to chicka in here and man look at
that trophy that's gonna be his in just
a second your arts limited hooked it up
moving on that is definitely one of the
most beautiful trophies I have ever seen
I mean give it for Tekken 7 nonetheless
means so much more and that's a
beautiful beautiful trophy but coming to
the stage Michael Murray and Harada will
be coming out for the award ceremony
make some guys make some noise don't
worry he'll miss you everybody me make
something got a stop we gotta do this
Hey ladies
[Music]
and after an amazing year an amazing
year we've had so many so many changes
to the game you see all these players
doing such a great job of adjusting
going to other countries to get that
experience and of course I believe
they're gonna present him with the
charger oh you want to show the Sun show
the Akuma sign on the back I'm seating
that poles are quite a few times yeah
but you see him there with his medal
there Harada getting me handing it to
chick or now but putting it on him he is
your 2019 champion right here and of
course let's not forget that Bureau are
limited trophy yo guys one more time
give it up for your champion of the GWT
2019 it's gonna be Chikara
[Applause]
man what a showing what a Shawn bit
playing his heart out all year multiple
carriages he went from the gym to the
keys pulls off the equipment lastly to
take it over everybody I mean what more
did you expect I mean we've seen so many
different equipment even through the LCQ
aways honey we thought it was gonna be
him everybody was cheering for him
everybody was willing to take it he was
like you know what now that both of
these cards are gone there's no other
Akuma's boom
surprise surprise Jesus come you thought
it was over you thought you were safe
from Akuma in the fireballs were wrong
again mm but man ol son almost after he
brought it back at the end he was
starting to figure it out but man you
know chickens just so good so good look
man I mean you just said you saw what
happened man Japan all ran up on us